P youtubers it's Charlie so Steven Amell
was dropping all kinds of bombs about
arrow episode 1 what's going to be
happening during season 6 like
Deathstroke being a huge part of the
season so let's break it down there's
also a bunch of cool Young Justice
season 3 stuff happening so I'll talk
about arrow first then I'll talk about
Young Justice later in the video there's
a new round of the flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so Stephen Amell was saying a whole
bunch of stuff answering questions about
episode 1 as well as the rest of the
series this is a little bit of him
talking about episode 1 specifically
whoever and Oliver Slade how the scene
in the photo day typical fires and
misses someone and then like he deploys
has done it and it doesn't work and and
he is enter present a scene where we
were at least eight to one another what
was happening there's he was playing
that game where he tells two truths 1
lie
I think the lie is that he talks to
Slade in present day because we know
that Slade's coming back in a separate
conversation he said oh yeah Manu
Bennett is coming back several times he
didn't say Deathstroke he said Manu
meaning that he'll be coming back and
playing the character himself because in
previous seasons when he wasn't
available they would put somebody else
in the Deathstroke costume and he
wouldn't speak so when this was
announced a lot of you guys were asking
me that question you're like wait a
minute is he coming back are they just
bringing the destro character back so
from the horse's mouth Stephen says he's
coming back several times and they
didn't say exactly what the storyline is
going to be but based on the way they
left things you can imagine it's going
to have something to do with his son
Joseph they say that family's a big
theme across season 6 it's going to be a
comic book fan favorite villain that
people have been asking for for a long
time so everyone immediately was like
that onomatopoeia is it going to be
Deathstroke and Oliver versus
onomatopoeia no confirmation on that
he's just one of the biggest fan
favorites the people have been asking
for he's from the Kevin Smith run so
it'd be interesting to see if Kevin
Smith ever directed an episode of arrow
it's one of the few shows that he hasn't
done yet is the other characters just
being like Richard dragon really big
significant character from Oliver's past
it's on the level with people like
Merlin but just slightly more terrible
and it all just depends on what they
want the villain to be doing because
they each have their different skills
but I feel like Richard Dragon is a much
bigger pick than onomatopoeia even
though he's a pretty cool villain to
most of the questions that I've gotten
are who died on the island and they
literally just posted this picture where
they're like we're back so it's pretty
much all the main cast members with the
exception of Merlin and Captain
Boomerang so when they posted this
people were like wait a minute Merlin's
in this picture that's just because he
goes to all kinds of conventions so
while it is possible we could see Merlin
in a flashback there will be at least
one flashback in the premiere just to
bridge the gap between this moment with
everything blowing up and them in
present-day
but I think for the most part just in
service of Thea's character development
and John Barrowman just feeling like
he's reached the end of his character
like there's not much more he can do
with them that in present-day Merlin has
ridden off into the sunset but they will
bring him back to guest star it'll just
be like a hallucination or earth to
Merlin or somebody else from a different
earth the outside chance though is that
they would kill the mother of Oliver's
child in Oliver would take a more active
role in parenting William which would be
really cool and even though I do think
that some day and whatever theoretical
future he has he would become a
vigilante to the Connor Hawke of the TV
show is John Diggle jr. that was the
legends of tomorrow thing they set up
they paid that off after flashpoint
by changing baby Sarah Diggle to baby
John Diggle jr. so that they could do
earth one connor hawke someday but
obviously he's a baby so you're not
going to see that play out on the TV
show is the title implies fall out it's
emotional fallout from the things that
happen people dealing with what happened
on the island dealing with the fallout
of prometheus as well as whatever
practical fallout of prometheus is
actions that will set the stage for the
new villain to swoop in they did confirm
that Oliver's going to have an apartment
so they'll be like a difference set that
they build for that and in the same
breath where Stephen Amell announced
that he also said that they're bringing
back a character that we haven't seen
since season one
most people think that it's race' the
maid who only appeared in the pilot and
she might just be another tenant of his
building or she might be his landlord in
some funny twist because even though he
has his own apartment he still hasn't
gotten his company back
so he's TV poor in the way that
billionaires are poor the way that
Steven Amell explained it he has like a
couple million dollars stashed away so
he has money for an apartment so I think
they're hoping you don't poke too many
holes in that but he's getting a new
apartment it should be a lot of fun and
they haven't said too much about what
Katie Cassidy is going to be doing is
black siren but she's a little more evil
than killer frost so they might try to
reform her but it just sounds like
she'll be flip-flopping back and forth
just having as much fun as possible I
think she's going to be a much more fun
character for Katie Cassidy to play just
because she has superpowers and she can
be bad so she could be a super to
everyone people have been talking about
a marriage to like Oliver and Felicity
getting married I don't know where
they're getting that I haven't heard
anything about that I think if anybody
is getting married this season it would
be Barry and iris
at the end of flash season four but they
haven't said anything about that either
only that he's coming back from the
Speed Force and they'll address that as
they get through the season but the cool
thing is is the one big point of
crossover people have been asking for
more flash arrow crossover they miss the
witty banter that Oliver and Barry get
to have they just had a comic book
crossover so if you guys aren't reading
the Green Arrow rebirth comic there's a
Barry Allen crossover happening right
now but because they're bringing back
the Suicide Squad via the flash like you
remember episode 22 we saw a gorilla
grodd King shark cheetah in Cupid
they're going to pay that off during
flash season four Oliver said that he
really wanted to fight King shark during
arrow season six so I feel like that's
him just winking at the back they'll be
doing some Suicide Squad stuff and
they'll probably use that for a
crossover episode Stephen was also
talking about being more like comic book
Oliver so that's one of the things I'm
looking forward to most but then you
have all the cool characters are
bringing back Suicide Squad King shark
vs. Green Arrow would be a badass
episode but I feel like bringing
Deathstroke back is probably going to be
the hook that gets most flash or other
DC TV people back who haven't been
watching arrow so if you're not caught
up these are to check it out on Netflix
it's not going to start for a while but
there will be a big comic-con trail
I'll do breakdown for it moving into
Young Justice season three so what's
happening right now is they're recording
episodes they've been working on it for
a while they just been doing it on the
DL it was an animated Justice League
reunion recently Cary Peyton was there
he announced that he'd been doing young
justice episodes Marina Sirtis who
played Queen Bee said that she's coming
back pretty much all the main cast
members for young justice are coming
back season three is titled Outsiders so
if you haven't read that comic book it's
Batman and the outsiders it's a team
that Batman funds of people whose main
mission is to infiltrate other
organizations in a really covert way
that the main teams like Justice League
don't necessarily do or aren't able to
do there's going to be a comic-con panel
they might show off footage or they
might show off animatics but they'll
definitely be teasing what's happening
so whatever it is I'll do a video for it
but as for airdate because it takes so
long to animate things I don't think
that it's going to drop before next
spring and it's going to be airing on
the DC streaming service everybody's
been asking a bunch of questions about
that if you're going to have to pay for
it is it going to be free and
ad-supported how is it going to work
when is it going to drop what other
shows are they going to have on it the
only thing that they've said is that
it's going to happen sometime next year
and they're using it to debuts a
live-action Titan show that Greg
Berlanti is producing you know mr.
arrowverse and this animated Young
Justice Season three there will
presumably be a bunch of other shows
that they do but I think these are just
the launch shows that they want to go
with so hopefully they'll make some
announcements about that later this year
whether or not you're gonna have to
shell out a bunch of money but I think
they'll find a way to make it worthwhile
like they'll have some sort of trial
period so you should be able to watch
episodes no problem but it's just Warner
Brothers and DC Comics trying to embrace
the idea that most people don't sit and
watch traditional TV anymore they stream
it on their computers on their devices
so it's just a different way of getting
the TV shows to you but what will happen
is we get closer to comic-con I'll
remind everybody to turn alerts on so
you don't miss any of the videos
there'll be a bunch of trailers all
kinds of crazy stuff happening
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner rocket Banuelos please private
message me so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here for brand new flash
one and you can click here for all my
spider-man easter-egg thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight